uniformed and plainclothes police
officers tried to stifle protests at a
shopping mall in Bangkok and the martial
law political gatherings of five or more
people are illegal six thousand soldiers
and police officers have blocked off
streets and squares in the capital
traders say it's bad for business hey
man my sales have fallen sharply
nobody's walking past here it's really
having an impact the new military rulers
want to quell opposition protests which
are often organized by a social media
networks despite the strict laws against
dissent demonstrators say they won't
allow themselves to be intimidated plum
I thought that the meaning of this sign
is that we're against the coup we want
democracy we don't want military control
these protesters have found a creative
way to express their opposition they
gather in groups of up to four people
and read books on dictatorship and
totalitarianism but the large deployment
of troops and police has done nothing to
calm the discontent many Thais feel
toward their government